ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung wie
immer sie ahnen es schon gibt es
zunächstes begriffsnetz was ihr schon
alle auswendig kennen auf Youtube und
hier im
Vorlesungssaal
aber es kommt noch was neues dazu wir
haben jetzt hier unten rechts sehen wir
jetzt plötzlich hier wird die Ecke die
freie Ecke hier unten rechts voll
sein und sollen haben das letzte Mal
noch mal ausführlich besprochen
und es gibt eine Spannung und sie haben
gesehen wie man versuchen kann diese
Kluft zwischen Sein und Säulen zu füllen
ich mache oben rechts dann auf Youtube
einen Link dazu rein ich sag nur es gibt
solche Begriffe wie zum Beispiel
Vernunft
oder wie zum Beispiel sowas wie ein Ziel
ein Zweck mit Hilfe von denen man
versuchen kann diese Kluft von seinen
sollen zu schließen wir werden heute
einen weiteren Begriff Kennenlernen der
möglicherweise diese Kluft
weiterschließen kann es ist der Begriff
des Lebens oder der Begriff der
Lebensform genauer gesagt werden das
noch genauer dann sehen die Folien
finden Sie immer auf Ilias die aktuellen
Folien und wir haben das letzte Mal
politische Gerechtigkeit Gerechtigkeit
diskutierte seine ganz vage Begriff ein
sehr normative Begriffe sehen Sie hier
er fällt unter Normativität und ich habe
ihn gleich unter moralisch genommen weil
häufig wird auch Gerechtigkeit als ein
moralisches Phänomen angesehen muss
nicht nur ein moralischen Kontexten kann
auch in politischen oder sozialen
Kontexten ähm betrachtet werden aber es
ist ein normative Begriff wer sagt das
ist gerecht oder vielleicht noch besser
gesagt das ist ungerecht er sagt dass
das nicht so sein sollte der hatte ein
sollenszustand ein solch ein sollen im
Kopf und der möchte dass dieses sollen
realisiert wird man kann sich darüber
streiten ob das eine ideal ist man
könnte sagen Gerechtigkeit ist eine
Utopie vielleicht auch wenn Sie das ist
ist sie natürlich ein wünschenswerter
Zustand und damit ist dann schnell
Normativität verbunden und jetzt habe
ich gesagt diese
diese Idee der Gerechtigkeit steht einer
Spannung zum Begriff des Neides wir
haben darüber diskutiert wir werden auch
heute noch mal ein bisschen die Sache
weiter klären der Neid Begriff ist
nämlich gar nicht so klar und das hat
auch ihre Umfrage gezeigt die mich
überrascht hat aber das hat nur gezeigt
dass ich ein sehr speziellen Leitbegriff
hatte der sich offenbar nicht mit dem
alltäglichenheit Begriff deckt und so
ist es leider häufig in der Philosophie
dass man viel zu spezielle Begriffe hat
muss immer schauen wie deckt sich das
mit der lebensweltlichen Bedeutung
dieser Begriffe dieser Wörter genau
genommen so jetzt haben wir hier
natürlich noch das Gute das wird heute
auch im Zentrum stehen ich habe das gute
wie Sie sehen auch zur Normativität
genommen ich habe sie auch das ist nicht
alles immer ganz perfekt geordnet aber
ich habe sie unter sollen genommen und
sie ahnen schon was der Gegenbegriff ist
natürlich das bösen das werden wir
übernächsten sie zu machen den nächsten
Sitzung geht's gut und dann geht's über
das Böse eines meiner Lieblingsfilme
habe ich
gestern kam ich im Schweizer Fernsehen
als Experte für true Crime-Serie True
Crime mache ich oben rechts ein Link
rein also echte Verbrechen Dokumentation
da wollte der Schweizer Fernsehen von
mir wissen warum schauen sich die Leute
eigentlich solche
Sendung an ich schaue es mir auch
manchmal an und habe ich versucht das
philosophisch zu analysieren also oben
rechts findet man dann auf Youtube den
Link zu diesem kurzen Interview und sie
sehen das Thema ist einfach aktuell und
wir Philosophie Philosophen können auch
zu True Crime Serien was sagen das ist
eine der vielen Gründe warum sie hier
philosophieren können Sie bekommen
Anfragen sie werden zu allen möglichen
Themen dann gebeten ihre begründete
Meinung zu tun das haben wir schon
diskutiert das ist die Justizia wir
haben die Allegorie sehr treffend
ausgedeutet dass Abwägen von Gründen
könnte man sagen sie können sich auch
die Gründe warum vorstellen ja wenn ein
Richter eine Richterin ein Urteil fällt
dann soll er oder sie das Gericht machen
sie muss beide Parteien wenn sie da zwei
Parteien streiten
anhören ja sie kennen den Spruch
audiator
Spuren heißt es soll auch die andere
Seite Gehör finden und so interpretiere
ich auch diese Waage also immer schön
beide Seiten wahrnehmen Gründe dafür
grüne gegen abwägen und diese Binde hier
die Augenbinde interpretiere ich so da
haben wir sind interpretiert das ist
eben eine gewisse Unvoreingenommenheit
sich nicht vielleicht durch
Äußerlichkeiten blenden lassen und hier
dieses Schwert kann eine gewisse Schärfe
des Urteils vielleicht auch der
Durchsetzung bedeuten weil man muss
immer nur ein bisschen aufpassen man
muss natürlich auch die judikativ also
das Urteil sprechende vom exekutiven
unterscheiden und ich weiß nicht
inwiefern hier dann noch eine Exekutive
bei der uniklinikativ ist wir haben
nicht ohne Grund hier die
Gewaltenteilung
all das muss man noch dahingestellt
lassen aber es soll jedenfalls die
Gerechtigkeit allegorisch darstellen und
wir haben uns dann gefragt was ist
politische Gerechtigkeit oder
Gerechtigkeit was macht unser
handelngerecht welche intersubjektiven
Strukturen fördern und beeinträchtigen
Gerechtigkeit da komme ich heute noch
mal auf John worlds zu sprechen ein ganz
bekannter politischer Philosoph der
zweiten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts der
hat ein Harvard gelehrt und der ist nach
wie vor der Bezugspunkt für Theorien der
Gerechtigkeit wir wollen uns fragen wie
sich Ungerechtigkeit und Ungleichheit
oder Gleichheit und Gerechtigkeit
sondern der Verhalten das ist ein neuer
Aspekt in der heutigen Vorlesung da
möchte ich Ihnen auch noch eine These
vorstellen das natürlich jetzt alles
Thesen die man kontrovers diskutieren
kann und dementsprechend werden sie auch
nur begrenzt Eingang in der Klausur
finden ja aber dass man zumindest mal
sagen kann was kann man alles unter
Gerechtigkeit verstehen das das wäre so
eine Art Frage natürlich die Diskussion
ist dann schon viel komplexer
häufig wird gesagt gerecht ist das was
gleich ist
ungerecht ist dann etwas wenn es nicht
gleich ist und dieses Verhältnis ist
spannend und da gibt es viele Thesen
dazu manche sagen wir sollten gar nicht
Gerechtigkeit über Gleichheit erzielen
wir sollten es versuchen anders zu
machen und dann möchte ich Ihnen heute
einfach ein paar Positionen vorstellen
dass sie einfach mal so ein gewisses
gewisse Bandbreite kennenlernt von
Theorien der Gerechtigkeit weil es gibt
ganz viele Versuche und Möglichkeiten
Gerechtigkeit zu begründen
wie verhalten sich Neid und
Gerechtigkeit da möchte ich auch noch
ein bisschen drauf eingehen im Zuge
unserer gestrigen Diskussion ja wir
hatten schon gesehen Neid gilt als
Jugend genau genommen als Leid sondern
Gerechtigkeit Gerechtigkeit geht als
Tugend genau genommen als
kardinalfugend und es gibt natürlich
auch normativ Auffassung oder
Gerechtigkeit ist in der Regel ein
normativer Begriff damit wird ein
Wunschzustand
ausdrückt eine Forderung nicht nur ein
Wunsch seine Forderung die begründet ist
wie verhalten sich Gerechtigkeit und
Rechtfertigung zueinander
häufig würde man sagen das was gerecht
ist und damit etwas gerecht ist muss es
auch gerechtfertigt werden können es
muss begründet werden können es muss
gute Gründe geben und etwas ist dann
ungerecht auch wenn man nicht mehr genug
gute Gründe einführen kann wenn man zum
Beispiel willkürlich Stichwort Willkür
Stichwort für fürstenwillkür wenn man
einfach etwas tut und sagt ich tue es
weil ich es kann weil ich es eben so
will ja fürstenwillkürlich angenommen
eine mächtige Fürstin setzt man sie mal
in die Vergangenheit im 18 Jahrhundert
die beschließt einfach dass ihre
Untertanen dass die jetzt nicht mehr 10%
Steuern abgeben sondern 20% und ferne
auch sonntags ah helfen ihre Burg zu
putzen und dann kann man sich natürlich
fragen wie kann ich das gerecht und sie
sagt ja weil ich das einfach dazu
bestimme da ist natürlich viele
Intuition zu sagen das ist nicht gerecht
was wäre dann gerecht wäre wenn
Arbeitspflichten
legitimiert sind also auch Legitimation
ist eine Rolle Partizipation wenn man
durch möglichst demokratische Verfahren
sich auf so ein eine Pflicht einnimmt
also wenn das jetzt endlich auch immer
von allen partizipierenden Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern oder Menschen auch am Ende
mitbestimmt werden also partizipation
ist auch sein Gedanke der mit
Gerechtigkeit zusammenhängt wir hatten
gesehen bei Aristoteles ich für den
jetzt nicht an ist Tugend eine
Charaktereigenschaft wird als
Kardinaltugend diskutiert es gibt noch
weitere die Mäßigung oder auch die
Besonnenheit die Tapferkeit und die
Weisheit das sind solche Tugenden die
ganz ganz wichtig sind in der Artikel
gibt es eine große Tugend Diskussion
jeder Philosoph jede Philosophie
natürlich irgendwie anders was jetzt zu
den Kardinaltugenden gehört aber
Gerechtigkeit ist vielleicht die
wichtigste dieser Kardinal Tugenden
dann haben wir gesagt Gerechtigkeit ist
ein relationaler und situativer Begriffe
es ist immer die Frage in welcher
Hinsicht ist etwas gerecht ja von was
sprechen wir was Gericht ist es kommt
auf die Kontexte an es hängt von
Umständen ab man führt häufig den
Gedanken der Gleichheit ein beruft sich
auf die des Ideal der Gleichheit wenn
man Gerechtigkeit begründen möchte oder
einfordert hier ist natürlich auch die
Frage was ist jetzt unter Gleichheit zu
verstehen sind wir alle gleich
inwiefern sollten alle die gleichen
Rechte und Pflichten haben ja schon eher
haben wir alle die die gleichen oder
vielleicht sogar selten Freiheiten die
Grundfreiheiten die muss man immer noch
genauer nachfragen was ist damit
eigentlich gemeint dann habe ich den
Begriff der Fairness gebracht natürlich
in einem bestimmten Sinne auch als
Gerechtigkeit verstanden werden kann
haben auch gute Argumente dafür gehört
dass vielleicht Fairness wenn man ihn
zumindest so im sportlichen Sinne
verwendet nicht ganz ausreicht um den
voll Sinn von auch politischer sozialer
Gerechtigkeit herzustellen Fairness
trifft in bestimmte Kontexte zu wenn es
kompetitive Situationen sind man denkt
natürlich da häufig an Fairplay ja die
Frage wäre ob ein Fairplay spielender
Fußballspieler ob der jetzt gerecht ist
ob man den jetzt als gerecht ansehen
würde aber würde sagen das was er tut
ist gerechtfertigt ich gebe Ihnen mal
ein Beispiel
eine Mannschaft A kämpft gegen im
Fußball gegen ein Spiel gegen eine
Mannschaft B und Mannschaft A ist kurz
davor ein Tor zu schießen aber der
Stürmer die stimmerin der Mannschaft ah
sieht da liegt eine Person der
Mannschaft B auf dem Boden und hat sich
verletzt
und der Stürmer der Mannschaft A sieht
es und spielt den Ball ins Aus obwohl er
ein Vorteil haben könnte von der
Situation weil die Mannschaft bete
Unterzahl ist weil da eine Person
verletzt auf dem Rad würde man sagen
dass auf jeden Fall Fairplay genau ein
anderes Beispiel wäre wenn jetzt eine
Spielerin ein Tor schießt aber dieses
Tor mit ihrer Hand
geschossen hat die kennen die berühmte
Person die mit ihrer Hand ein Tor
geschossen hat in der Geschichte der
Philosophie immer alles ein
Fußballspielerin und sie hat ihre Hand
im Spiel gehabt das natürlich verboten
nach den schwierigen und wenn sie dann
sagt obwohl der Schiedsrichter gesagt
hat das ist ein Tor und sie sagt nein
ich muss zu gestehen da war meine ernten
spielen und das eingestehen und das Tun
nicht zählen ist fair und wir würden
natürlich auch dieser Person großen
Respekt sein natürlich vor allem die
gegnerische Mannschaft ob die eigenen
Fans das täten ist eine andere Frage hat
und hier sieht mir jetzt es hat gewisse
Momente von Gerechtigkeit es ist
natürlich im Sinne der Spielregeln und
die werden berücksichtigt insofern kann
man schon sagen ist direkt aber es hat
noch ein engeren Sinn weil auch eine
ganz spezifische Situation bezogen ja
gewisse Spielregeln man muss sich jetzt
immer fragen wie kann man eine
Gesellschaft eine komplexe Gesellschaft
als ein komplexes Spiel ansehen ist es
nicht eine ein falsches ist die
Gesellschaft als großes Fußballspiel
sich vorzustellen das möchte ich einfach
nur mal so zu bedenken geben
ungerecht wenn man jetzt oder gerecht
können nicht nur Personen oder ihre
Handlung sein ist auch ganz wichtig
sondern soziales Strukturen und
Institutionen da denken Sie dran an die
Feudalherrschaft
Mittelalter oder denken Sie an andere
Situation auch auf der Welt wo Menschen
Karten die selben Freiheiten genießen
wie in anderen Regionen der Welt wo sie
nicht demokratisch partizipieren können
wo ihn gewisse Grundfreiheiten fehlen
aufgrund von Institutionen von
herrschaftsfor
von
bücke allen möglichen Einschränkungen da
könnte man auch sagen diese
Sozialstrukturen sind nicht gerecht weil
sie nicht allen Menschen die gleichen
Grundfreiheiten
lassen da werden jetzt nicht alle
Menschen gleich angesehen aber sie haben
die gleichen Grundrechte natürlich auch
Pflichten eines anderen Rechte und
Pflicht werden man kann natürlich auch
nur Rechte haben wenn man Pflichten hat
und wir sehen hier im rechten
Gerechtigkeit hängen auch miteinander
zusammen es gibt natürlich auch Zustände
des Rechts die rechtlich geregelt sind
wo keine Gerechtigkeit nicht überall da
wo recht herrscht Gesetze herrschen die
juristisch begründet werden nicht
überall da muss dann auch irgendwie
Gerechtigkeit im vollen Sinne Geld das
alle Menschen die selben Freiheiten
haben und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen noch
mal kurz schon rolls vorstellen
Bild von ihm und er hat zwei Bücher
geschrieben und das erste was ich ihnen
zeige ist das wichtig dieses Buch das
ist seine Theorie der Gerechtigkeit als
Fury of Justice das ist wirklich das
Standardwerk also wer sich mit
Gerechtigkeit beschäftigen möchte der
kommt um dieses Buch nicht herum hier
werden bestimmt auch in Konstanz
Seminare dazu angeboten also wenn Sie
sich interessieren besuchen Sie mal ein
solches Seminar und er hat und deswegen
habe ich ja auch einen Titel
Gerechtigkeit als Fairness geschrieben
er hat eben auch ein Buch verfasst mit
dem Titel justice entfernt ist das ist
dann eine ein restatement wie ist der
Untertitel sagt also ein ganz zentraler
Philosophie ich möchte jetzt mal noch
ein paar Passagen und seine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit vorstellen und wir
diskutieren dann auch noch ein bisschen
genau drüber wie man das jetzt zu
verstehen hat ob das wirklich
Gerechtigkeit
hört und welcher Gerechtigkeitsbegriff
hier zugrunde liegt er sagt jeder Mann
soll gleiches Recht auf das
umfangreichste System gleicher
Grundfreiheiten haben das mit dem
gleichen System für alle anderen
verträglich ist beide sagt der soziale
und wirtschaftliche Ungleichheiten sind
so zu gestalten als er geht davon aus
dass es immer soziale und
wirtschaftliche Ungleichheiten gibt als
seine Theorie der Gerechtigkeit rechnet
immer schon mit Ungleichheiten die er
nicht leugnet also sehr realistische
Position und diese Ungleichheiten sind
so zu gestalten dass A vernünftigerweise
zu erwarten ist dass sie zu jedermanns
Vorteil dienen und B sie mit Positionen
Ämtern verbunden sind die jedem offen
stehen
ja dann möchte ich jetzt mal kurz mit
ihnen gleich drüber diskutieren ich
möchte aber noch ein eine andere Sache
ihnen zeigen und zwar das
differenzprinzip das ist auch noch ein
ganz wichtiges Prinzip seine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit ich lese mal vor dass wir
verstehen was darunter zu verstehen ist
geht man von den Institutionen aus wie
sie von der gleichen Freiheit für alle
und der fairen Chancengleichheit
gefordert werden das haben wir
vorherigen Forderungen gesehen das sind
die besseren Aussichten der begünstigten
also der besser gestellten dann gerecht
wenn sie zur Verbesserung der Aussichten
die am wenigsten begünstigten Mitglieder
der Gesellschaft beitragen der intuitive
Gedanke ist der dass die
Gesellschaftsordnung nur dann günstigere
Aussichten für bevorzugte einrichten und
sichern darf wenn das den weniger
begünstigten zum Vorteil gereicht also
ganz interessant er diskut die
Ungerechtigkeit der begünstigten also im
Vergleich zu den weniger begünstigten
immer ausgehend von der Situation der
weniger begünstigt also das ist
sozusagen der Gradmesser daran richtet
sich das Ganze aus dass das
differenzprinzip und noch ein weiteres
eine weitere Charakterisierung also
Differenz kann man auch als Ungleichheit
bezeichnen und eine Differenz zwischen
den Begünstigten und weniger
begünstigten könnte man sagen er sagt
weiter soziale und wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheiten sind so zu regeln dass
sie den am wenigsten begünstigten die
bestmöglichen Aussichten bringen ja
darüber würde ich jetzt gerne auch kurz
diskutieren halten Sie das für ein
klugen Schachzug Gerechtigkeit
immer fest zu machen an dem Zustand der
weniger begünstigt
ja wir haben gesehen dass Deutschland
rolls verschiedene interessante Ansätze
zur Gerechtigkeit existieren auch das
differenzprinzip das man immer sich an
den weniger begünstigten orientieren
muss und dass die wirtschaftlichen
Ungleichheiten so zu regeln sind dass
sie den am wenigsten begünstigten die
bestmöglichen Aussichten bringen er
bezieht sich auf das Pareto-Prinzip 2018
ist das Stichwort will da jetzt aber
auch nicht weitergehen und jetzt haben
wir diskutiert wie sieht's eigentlich
mit Ungleichheit aus wie verhalten sich
Gerechtigkeit zugleichheit und
Ungerechtigkeit zu Ungleichheit und da
haben sie sehr zurück darauf hingewiesen
dass wir uns darüber Gedanken machen
müssen
den netten Herrn hier kennen sie schon
Harry Frank wird der wird hier fast
jeder Vorlesung gebracht weil ich ihn
einfach sehr gut finde und er hat ein
Buch geschrieben und das ist jetzt
tatsächlich das Cover das ist jetzt hier
nicht von mir falsch ausprobiert das ist
tatsächlich das Cover
an eine quality eines wirklich so
abgeschnitten
und also er hat hier ein interessanten
Essay Harry Frank wird ist ihnen
vielleicht schon bekannt von anderen
Essays wer kennt den Essay on Bullshit
einfach mal melden noch nicht also über
Bullshit sehr lesenswert
darüber mal auch vielleicht mal eine
Veranstaltung zu machen und Bullshit
besorgen sich das können Sie vielleicht
auch irgendwie online kaufen oder so ein
ganz kurzer SC er beschreibt was
Bullshit ist und was es bedeutet zu
schicken und er sagt kurz gesagt jemand
der Bullshit produziert er schält sich
nicht um die Wahrheit hingegen der lügt
der kalkuliert immer noch mit der
Wahrheit der lügt der weiß genau was
waren falsch ist und deswegen kann er ja
nur Lügen um die andere Person zu
täuschen weil er weiß was ich weiß
welchen Frank wird sagt die meisten also
viele Leute bestimmten Position der
eigentlich gar nicht um die Wahrheit und
das Verhältnis von Wahrheit und
Falschheit und deswegen ist Bullshit
viel schlimmer als Lüge das ist sehr
provokativsinniger Ansatz und im
ähnlichen Stil hat er jetzt diesen
quality geschrieben ich lese ihn jetzt
nur was vor aus der verlagsankündigung
have in Love because others have more
and have too much
soweit
distress by the rich and by the pur
also worauf konzentrieren wir uns in
this provokativ book the number one user
times best selling order on will shit
presence and setting responsed to those
to believe the goal of social justice
should be economic equality all has enig
quality also das Ziel sollte es sein
ökonomische Gleichheit oder weniger
Ungleichheit Harry Frankfurt one of the
most Inflation
als wir sollten uns nicht so sehr auf
die Frage nach Gleichheit oder
Ungleichheit konzentrieren sondern wir
sollten uns einfach nur auf die Armut
konzentrieren und die beseitigen ein
Zitat at the same time Frankfurt audious
that the conjuiction of warst world and
Prodigy ist Offensive
to making to everyone has in love we
Mary use in quality as a side Effekt
die alte mit Girl justice ist to end
parity Nord quality also sie sehen es
gibt ganz verschiedene Auffassung von
Gerechtigkeit ne alte mit girl of
Justice ist
Hauptziel der Gerechtigkeit sollte nicht
sein
Ungleichheit zu beenden sondern Armut zu
beenden und als zeiteneffekt als
Nebeneffekt der Beseitigung oder
Bekämpfung von Armut so Frankfurt könnte
auch die Ungleichheit
verringert also damit will ich nur sagen
wenn es um Gleichheit Ungleichheit geht
deswegen war sehr gut dass sie das den
Punkt angesprochen haben gibt es ganz
verschiedene Auffassung in der
philosophieren es geht immer um die
guten Gründe die man für diese Position
anführt ist serious challenge to the
cherry beliebt und Ghost the police
Politiker left and Ride only quality
promises to have a profile impact und
one of the great de Dates auf all time
also es ist natürlich eine der großen
momentanen debatten wie sieht's aus mit
der Ungleichheit in der Welt wie können
wir Gerechtigkeit globale Gerechtigkeit
global Justiz ist gerade so das
Stichwort wie können wir global justice
herstellen können wir überhaupt sollen
wir über den gleichheitsaspekt den
gleichheitsgedanken oder
ungleichheitsgedanken Gerechtigkeit
herstellen oder über den armutsgedanken
es gibt ganz verschiedene
Herangehensweise bei solche Gedanken der
philosophisch weiter zu konzipieren das
möchte ich nur noch erwähnt haben und
jetzt bringe ich Ihnen noch mal ihre
Abstimmungsergebnisse über die
zugegebene Maßen sehr wahre Frage das
ist natürlich eine provokative Frage und
zwar aus zwei Gründen einmal ist der
Neid Begriff völlig unklar wie ich auch
jetzt gestern sehen musste und das
wusste ich aber gerechtfertigt ist auch
völlig
ambivalent ja und die Frage die ich
hingestellt habe war sie am gewinnen und
dementsprechend war auch ihre Antwort ja
sehr eindeutig ausgefallen ist
ambivalent ja und ich versuche jetzt mal
zu rekonstruieren was Sie damit sagen
wollten die 85% und was die 15 Prozent
auch sagen wollen also die die Ansicht
der 85%, weil sie ja alle moralische
Wesen sind sie sind ja nicht böse ne
also sie schauen noch nicht immer nur
True Crime an die haben sich gedacht so
meine Interpretation Neid ist natürlich
gerechtfertigt in Situation wenn ich
damit auf
ungerechte Situation hinweist wenn ich
Neid empfinde dann empöre ich mich über
ungerechte Zustände wenn ich die
Empörung über ungerechte Zustände Neid
nenne dann ist natürlich
neidgerechtfertig klar weil
Ungerechtigkeit ist nicht okay und meine
Reaktion auf Ungerechtigkeit wenn ich
sie nein nenne ist natürlich dann okay
also so kann man natürlich auch
irgendwie Neid verstehen
und man kann aber leider auch anders
verstehen in einem schärferen Sinne also
in dem nicht so alltagssprachlichen
Sinne und zwar wie ich schon mal vorhin
gesagt habe in der Diskussion als
Missgunst als ich gönne eine Person
etwas nicht obwohl sie es eigentlich
verdient hat das ist der wichtige Zusatz
und wenn man so Neid versteht ist
natürlich Neid nicht mit guten Gründen
zu rechtfertigen weil warum sollte ich
eine anderen Person etwas
absprechen was sie verdient hat und was
mir nicht schade ich sollte diese
anderen Person wenn Sie es wirklich
verdient hat also wenn es auf gerechte
Weise dazu gekommen ist das kann man
alles da reinpacken wenn sie nicht
gecheatet hat wenn sie nicht aufgrund
von irgendwelchen bevorzugen wohin
gekommen ist und wenn Sie es wirklich
verdient hat warum sollte ich diese
Person nicht Anerkennung sollen ja und
ich finde überhaupt eine Gesellschaft
die Anerkennung oder Respekt im Sinne
von ja Wertschätzung praktisch sich zum
Prinzip macht die ist sicherlich auch
eine gerechtere Gesellschaft wo man
Anerkennung Zeug wenn sie wirklich
verdient ist sie sehen es war mein meine
Schuld dass ich dass diese Frage hier so
beantwortet wurde und noch schlimmer ist
der Begriff der Gerechtigkeit
gerechtfertigung der Frage ob etwas
gerechtfertigt ist weil
selbst der missgünstige Neid wenn ich
also eine Person etwas eigentlich
verdientes nicht gönne
selbst der dieser Neid basiert auf
Rechtfertigung er ist nicht
gerechtfertigt im moralischen Sinne
natürlich ist er nicht gerechtfertigt
aber natürlich rechtfertige ich indem
ich eine andere Person etwas nicht gönne
da ging bin ich natürlich auch
Internationalisierung Strategien
eingebunden da ich versuche Gründe
anzuführen warum diese Person dieses Gut
nicht haben darf ich versuche es ihr
abspänzlich zu machen auch wenn ich
eigentlich nicht darin gerechtfertigt
bin ich führe Gründe dazu an und das
heißt ich rechtfertig also diese Frage
war sie sind sehr ambivalent aber
interessant dieses Ergebnis dass doch
die meisten von ihm so ein
lebensweltlichen alltäglichen
begriffenheit voraussetzen und nicht den
mir viel präsenter gewesen sind
negativen Neid als Missgunst das zeigt
dass man hier noch viel mehr
differenzieren muss und da habe ich
jetzt viel davon gelernt
man kann also zwischen Gerechtigkeit der
objektiven Gerechtigkeit und der
Rechtfertigung unterscheiden und nicht
alles was wir recht fertigen ist dann am
Ende auch gerecht gerechtfertigt
sozusagen also es gibt Rechtfertigung
die nicht gerechtfertigt sind das klingt
jetzt ein bisschen paradox aber in
missgünstigen Neid ist es der Fall da
versuche ich eine andere Person etwas ja
abzustreiten mit gewissen Argumenten ich
versuchte also zu rechtfertigen ich tue
es auch aber eben nur in meiner
subjektiven Form und es ist nicht
objektiv
missgünstig neidische Menschen nenne ich
das in deswegen jetzt immer und nicht
einfach nur neidische das habe ich jetzt
noch präzisiert missgünstig neidische
Menschen Person berufen sich immer auch
auf das Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit die
sagen das ist nicht fair
aber sie berufen sich zu Unrecht auf das
Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit der
missgünstige Neid zu meine These ist
objektiv nicht direkt fertig aber
subjektiv schon wir leiden darin und wir
können uns nicht eingestehen dass eine
andere Person mehr hat als wir dass sie
zu Recht eigentlich mehr hat als wir
bewundern sie aber wir schaffen es nicht
hier Anerkennung zu zahlen obwohl sie es
wirklich gerechterweise hat also ganz
fair ist hingekommen wir haben da gar
kein moralischen Kunde das wirklich
abzusprechen aber leider gibt's die
Situation wo wir selbst in solchen
Situationen nicht die Größe dazu haben
der anderen Person zu sagen gratulation
tolle Leistung das ist ein riesen
Problem dieses missgünstigen nein
rationalisieren die Situation so dass
die Überlegenheit der anderen Person bzw
unsere eigene Unterlegenheit als
ungerecht erscheint wir beziehen uns nur
scheinbar darauf aber eigentlich haben
wir gar kein Recht bitte sagen das ist
Unrecht
und deswegen muss man immer so ein
bisschen aufpassen mit Neid also ein
bisschen Sticker night der ist eine Form
von anerkennungsverweigerung und dem
Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit auf ganz
verschiedene Weise entgegengesetzt zum
einen weil wir nicht fair sind die
anderen Personen Respekt zollen und zum
anderen weil wir uns auf das Prinzip der
Gerechtigkeit beziehen und es eigentlich
missbrauchen wir müssen brauchen das
Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit nur für unsere
eigenen Zwecke um uns am Ende dann zu
immunisieren um uns eine Trost zu geben
weil wir es nicht ertragen dass wir
vielleicht in manchen Hinsichten nicht
so gut sind wie andere die ist aber
wirklich verdient haben und das ist ein
Problem der Selbsttäuschung gemerken in
diesen missgünstigen Neid häufig nicht
dass wir neidisch sind ja
missgünstigend sind wir uns das nicht
bewusst und denken ich bin doch zu Recht
empört gegenüber diese diese Person wie
soll ich denn neidisch sein wenn wir
dann gesagt bekommen du bist doch nur
neidisch dann rechtfertigen wir uns und
versuchen zu sagen nein nein das ist
gerecht also das will ich einfach noch
zeigen das interessant ist Phänomen
jetzt habe ich genug über den Neid
gesagt jetzt will ich noch was über das
gute sagen wir können nämlich uns fragen
wie wir das moralisch gute definieren
können wie wir das moralisch gute
erkennen können die memoralisch gut
handeln können wie sich praktische und
das Gute zueinander verhalten wie sich
menschliche Natur oder überhaupt die
Natur und das Gute das moralisch gute
zueinander verhalten darauf möchte ich
heute vor allem eingehen natürlich kann
man sich auch noch fragen wie sich
Gerechtigkeit und das moralisch gute
zueinander verhalten ist immer das
Gericht was gut ist dann ist über das
gut was gerecht ist wie verhalten sich
diese zwei Begriffe sondern das auch
eine spannende Frage jetzt möchte ich
dir mal bitte ein bisschen aktivieren
und möchte Ihnen eine Frage geben ich
hoffe dass das klappt es gibt einen
Spruch von Erich Kästen haben schon
gehört es gibt nichts Gutes außer man
tut es
schön heute haben mehr teilgenommen
gestern waren es nur 21 heute haben 23
teilgenommen sie sehen die Ergebnisse es
ist ziemlich ausgeglichen 24 es ist
ziemlich ausgeglichen
ja sagen 45 Prozent und nein sagen
54% und natürlich ist es eine spannendes
Ergebnis und da möchte ich jetzt auch
mal eine ganz kurze Diskussionsrunde
machen und sie fragen was spricht dafür
für ja und was spricht für nein
also der Begriff des Guten ist gar nicht
eindeutig bestimmt Erich Kästner dachte
sicherlich so interpretiere ich
jedenfalls wir sollen nicht nur
nachdenken und fromme Wünsche äußern
oder auch nur an Willen bilden sondern
wir sollen es auch in die Realität
überführen wie wir aber auf unseren
betriebsnitz gesehen haben gibt es auch
innere Handlung die jetzt vielleicht
nicht in diesem Sinne zu verstehen sind
wie Erich Kästen aber die man vielleicht
auch gut nennen könnte wenn man nämlich
seine Maxim richtig bildet und am 7
gesetzt worden
jetzt ist das Gute wie sie alle schon
wissen ein normativer Begriff also das
Gute ist wie wir gesehen haben Stichwort
naturalistischer Fehlschluss nur sehr
problematisch über naturalistische
Prädikate zu definieren über angenehm
nützlich es kann aber dennoch sagen man
kann eine utilitaristische Auffassung
des Guten vertreten und die Leute ein
gutes das was den meisten Menschen nützt
und Nutzen bringt das Problem ist
natürlich das wie definieren wir nutzen
um wie definieren wir den meisten
Menschen überhaupt manchmal sagt man
auch nur dass das den größten Nutzen
bringt dann muss man sich fragen für wen
ist der Nutzen ist es der Nutzen für
Menschen ist es der Nutzen für nicht
menschliche Lebewesen ist es der Nutzen
für Pflanzen oder ist es der Nutzen für
die ganze Welt sind die Erde die als
Person verstanden wird Stichwort ja ja
es gibt Position
die ganze Erde die müssen wir als eine
Art von Person verstehen die nennen wir
Geier Gaia ist nämlich beim griechisch
und steht für die Erde also es ist
völlig unklar wem der nutzen gilt ja das
ist ein Problem istarismus wir kann
sagen gut sind tugendhaste Handlung zum
Beispiel gerechte Handlungen das wäre
dann so eine Auffassung gut ist das was
aus einer tugendhaften Haltung
entspricht gut sind die Handlungen denen
Tugenden zugrunde liegen z.B die
kardinaltugen Gerechtigkeit
besonnenheitenmäßigung Tapferkeit
vielleicht auch Vernünftigkeit das wäre
eine Antwort auf die Frage oder die
dontologie geht deswegen nur kurz darauf
ein weil es noch eine parallele
Vorlesung zum Moralphilosophie gibt auf
dich wenn ich näher eingehen möchte die
deontologie das ist ja immer kann so
nennt man die Position gut sind
diejenigen Maximen und nicht Handlungen
oder vielleicht Handlungen denen gute
maximum Sekunde liegen deswegen müssen
wir gleich von Maxim sprechen also
diejenigen die sich
allgemeinen lassen wir sind daraus schon
ausführlich darauf eingegangen ich mache
dann auch oben rechts den Link rein zu
der Sitzung wo wir es von kann und
seinem maximentest hatten also wie man
gut bestimmt hängt natürlich immer von
der uralphilosophischen Position ab die
wir als Hintergrund haben genauso
natürlich auch gerecht das möchte ich
Ihnen nun ganz kurzes Schema geben wie
sich das vorstellen können also die
deontologie oder Pflichten die
betrachtet das Verhältnis von Motivation
und Intention den Gründen zur Handlung
bis dahin Ziel die deontologie ab kann
sagt die Konsequenzen der Handlung oder
auch meiner Motivation die gehen nicht
in die Beurteilung
sie sind nicht relevant für die
moralische Bewertung die Ideologie der
Pflichten die betrifft das Verhältnis
von unserer Motivation Intention zur
Handlung das ist diese Fokus während der
solitarismus das Verhältnis von Handlung
und Konsequenzen betrachtet und nicht so
sehr die Motivation den Blick nimmt die
dahinter liegt sie sehen immer es hängt
davon ab welchen Fokus wir haben es gibt
verschiedene Argumente eben auch zu
sagen um zu bestimmen was Gutes sollten
immer die Motivation
zugrunde liegen ich habe da ein Beispiel
immer was ich anführe Mutter Teresa ein
Gedanken Beispiel Mutter Teresas
versteckte Tagebücher wurden gefunden
das ist eine reine Illusion oder Theresa
gilt gemeint als eine Person die sehr
viel Gutes getan hat manche sagen sogar
sie war ein guter Mensch ich bin immer
vorsichtig davon zu sprechen dass ein
Mensch gut ist oder ein Mensch böse ist
ich glaube nur Handlungen oder
vielleicht nur Maximen sind gut aber sag
mal mal von Mutter Teresa würden geheime
Tagebücher entdeckt werden in denen sie
gesteht dass sie nur deswegen so viele
gute Handlung vollzogen hat um
irgendwann mal als guter in die
Geschichte einzugehen so und jetzt kann
man sich fragen ändert das an der
Bewertung ihrer Handlung etwas also
ändert es was wenn wir jetzt von den
Handel und Konsequenzen auf die
Motivation auf die Gründe gehen dazu
beigetragen haben und jetzt gibt es
natürlich zwei auffassen dazu man kann
sagen es ändert gar nichts dran unter
Theresa hat selbst mit so einer
Motivation vielen Menschen geholfen das
ist völlig egal
es gibt aber auch die andere Auffassung
die vielleicht ein bisschen stärker ist
ja sagen würde zu einem Fall würde ich
die Handlungen doch etwas
problematisieren weil sie eigentlich
nicht eine wirklich gute Motivation
hatten die Handlung war letztendlich gar
nicht uneigennützig wie man es immer
gedacht hat sondern die waren eigene
sich wenn natürlich nicht aus
finanziellen Interessen aber doch um
eben in die Geschichte als gute Person 1
Kind ich möchte jetzt gar nicht weiter
darüber diskutieren aber sie sehen es
ist ein Problem und es ist nicht trivial
ob man die Motivation von Handlung mit
in die Bewertung Behandlung einbezieht
ob sie gut sind oder vielleicht nicht
gerade böse aber vielleicht eben nicht
doch so gut wie man ursprünglich dachte
das ist das Argument der deontologie die
Motivation die hinter den Handlungen
steht die zählt immer auch obwohl die
Handlung denselben Nutzen bringen können
vielleicht
ja und jetzt möchte ich noch zum Schluss
auch die Position des sogenannten
ethischen Naturalismus eingehen diese
ethische Naturalismus betrifft die Frage
nach dem Verhältnis von gut oder
moralisch und Natur darauf sind wir
heute auch schon eingegangen es gibt von
Philippa food einer bekannten englischen
Philosophie ein Buch mit dem Titel
natural goodness und die deutsche
Übersetzung lautet die Natur des Guten
ähm genau genommen müsste man eine
übersetzen natürliche Gutheit ne die
Natur des Guten ist natürlich schon eine
freie Übersetzung eine sehr
einflussreiche Position und diese Bücher
oder dieses Buch genau genommen muss ich
sagen betrifft die Frage wie verhält
sich das moralisch gut oder das Gute zu
unserem Leben unserem Leben
wie urteilen wir über unser Leben und
wie urteilen wir über das gute es geht
Dir also um die Frage wie wir urteilen
sie sagt in der Art und Weise wir über
das gute urteilen und über das Leben
urteilen gibt es viele in dieser Weise
gibt es viel Ähnlichkeiten wir können
das also ziemlich ähnlich fassen kurz
gesagt will sie diesen Problem des
naturalistischen fehlschlusses der
natürlich bei mir sofort hier als
Alarmglocke aufgeleuchtet hatte sehr
klar sie haben jetzt sofort gesagt
naturalistischer Fehlschluss na wie kann
man denn von einem natürlichen guten
sprechen das ist doch praktisch nicht
erlaubt weil ich das Gute doch gar nicht
definieren kann übernatürliche
Eigenschaften ja da ist natürlich die
nur dahinter das wusste natürlich für
die paar food auch weil sie natürlich
den nur gut kannte und sie sagt trotzdem
versuche ich diese naturalistischen
Fehlschluss zu entgehen ich habe das
immer schon im Hinterkopf dieses Problem
oder auch das sein soll das Problem
dennoch möchte ich über Bezug auf den
Naturbegriff des natürliche meinen
Begriff des Guten vielleicht auch das
moralisch guten erklärenden
ich kam zu der Auffassung dass es
unmöglich war das Besondere an der Idee
des Guten zu erklären ohne dass man über
die besondere Art und Weise nachdenkt
wie wir die Welt der Lebewesen
beschreiben
also es geht jetzt nicht so sehr um die
Natur genau genommen sondern es geht um
das Leben den Lebensbegriff und sie
erinnern sich noch an diese Kluft von
sein und sollen die ihn hier mal hier an
der Tafel gezeigt hat die man mit
weiteren Prämissen und schwachen
zusatzannahme schließen und habe ich ihn
gesagt der Begriff des Lebens der ist
auch ein möglicher Kandidat diese Luft
zu schließen neben dem Begriff der
Vernunft weil diese Begriffe zweideutig
sind die haben eine deskriptive Seite
sie haben aber auch eine normative Seite
und wir verwenden diese Begriffe
selbstverständlich denn unsere
Alltagsprache ohne dass sie irgendwelche
großartig
ausgedachten zusatzanlagen darstellt ist
also ihre herangehen sie sagt wir fragen
uns praktisch können wir moralische
Normativität bzw das moralisch gute
durch Bezug auf den Begriff des Lebens
oder die Lebensform ist
meistens die Frage ist Leben ein
normativer Begriff wenn Sie die Biologie
Fragen werden sie hören was ist
überhaupt normativ so vielleicht nicht
so schlimm vielleicht nicht aber da
werden sie ungläubige Gesichter bekommen
und dann wird Ihnen die Professoren
sagen also was wollen Sie hier
eigentlich ja also Leben ist allein
schon ein Begriff den wir in der
Biologie vielleicht gar nicht verwenden
vermutlich jetzt ein viel zu unklarer
Begriff noch viel schlimmer sei deutlich
als der Begriff des Neides total die Fuß
mit dem Lebensbegriff werden positive
Dinge konnotiert Hoffnungen lebendig
vital der eignet sich vielleicht gar
nicht so sehr wenn eine gute biologische
Beschreibung was sagt sie jetzt ich
denke das Zuschreibungen von gut
ausnahmslos auf die Welt der Lebewesen
als auch Pflanzen Tiere und Menschen
bezogen sind und dass die Vorstellung
von gut und schlecht ohne den Begriff
des Lebens Inhalt sehr wäre
eine starke these in einem Universum dem
es keine Lebensform geht als keine Wesen
die Leben wäre nichts entweder gut oder
schlecht man kann nur annehmen etwas in
diesem unfruchtbaren Universum sehr gut
wenn man sich stillschwein auf etwas
bezieht das ist in unserem Universum
gibt beziehungsweise geben könnte
in Wirklichkeit sprechen wir manchmal
davon dass etwas bei bestimmten Arten
von Lebewesen gut ist wie zum Beispiel
kräftige Wurzeln bei Eichen oder
Schnelligkeit bei Fluchttieren und wir
können auch davon sprechen was bezogen
auf bestimmte Arten von Lebewesen gut
ist wie zum Beispiel besondere
Mistplätze für Vögel und
selbstverständlich ist unser zugspunkt
auf das menschliche Leben
oder wir beziehen uns auf einzelne
Menschen mit besonderen Bedürfnissen und
Interessen die Moralphilosophie sagt sie
ist nichts anderes als ein zwei einer
Untersuchung des Guten dass in einer
besonderen und allgemein Weise zum
menschlichen Leben gehört als über das
Leben möchte sie jetzt das gute Stimmen
auf die Art und Weise
bringt sie ein Beispiel was denn
vielleicht nicht gut ist ich sage jetzt
nicht böse man wird sicherlich nicht
bestreiten dass mit dem
trittbrettfahrenden Wolf als ein Wolf
der Frist aber nicht an der Jagd
teilnehmen also ein
unfairer Wolf ein egoistischer der der
ist Rudel jagte nicht und und die lässt
die anderen jagen und bis dann trotzdem
was etwas nicht in Ordnung ist dasselbe
gilt für eine Biene die einen Nektar
will entdeckt deren Verhalten anderen
Bienen aber nicht mitteilt wo diese zu
finden ist also eine fiese Biene diese
tritt fahren Individuen einer Spezies
der Mitglieder zusammenarbeiten sind
ebenso defekt wie diejenigen die ein
schadhaftes Gehör C oder
Bewegungsvermögen
als ist mangelnde Kooperation ein Defekt
der dann vielleicht sogar böse genannt
werden kann
musste natürlicher Normativität sagt sie
jetzt die finden wir wir finden wir
dieselbe urteilsstruktur fragt sie wenn
wir zunächst von Pflanzen und Tieren zu
Menschen übergehen und dann von der
Bewertung menschliche Eigenschaften und
Vollzüge im Allgemeinen zu Bewertung des
Willens im Besonderen als ich frag gibt
es ein Übergang von der Beschreibung der
Natur auch als Defekt hin zum Willen der
natürlich eigentlich erst moralisch
genannt werden kann ja das ist sozusagen
die These heute gewesen wir haben noch
ganz kurz Zeit für ein kleines Feedback
zu dieser naturalistischen ethischen
Theorie und dann geht's morgen weiter
mit dem Guten